bonsoir et bienvenue donc ce que la
dernière émission culturelle de l'année
2014 et pour vous permettre de passer en
transition en toute en douceur en 2015
je vais vous proposer pendant une
demi-heure un passage en revue des
activités que vous pouvez faire pendant
ces vacances de Noël alors nous irons
tout d'abord à l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'Office qui
propose toute une thématique autour de
la neige Géraldine 2e sera le point pour
nous le château de Bretagne ne prend pas
de vacances visite guidée atelier et
couture séance de compte au programme
Irène marphin guide conférencière et
conteuse nous en parlera dans quelques
instants vous aimez patiner bien ça
tombe bien il y a deux patinoires qui
sont accessibles jusqu'au 4 janvier à
Trappes et à Versailles et bien d'autres
idées à découvrir dans ce kiosque
spécial fin d'année
et on démarre tout de suite avec
l'Office de Tourisme de 50 ans en
Yvelines l'Office de Tourisme qui reste
ouvert pour accueillir le public pendant
les vacances l'occasion aussi de jeter
un coup d'œil sur les ateliers proposés
explications avec Géraldine 2e
ici on se trouve à l'Office de Tourisme
pour une exposition de photos jusqu'au 3
janvier combien de photos et quel
paysage alors vous avez ici une
vingtaine de photos de 50 ans living
sous la neige effectivement l'office de
tourisme de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
propose une exposition Noël tous les ans
et cette année nous avons choisi le
thème de la neige et
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sous la neige
qui a réalisé ses photos oui ce sont des
photographes locaux vous avez Francis
tac et Christian leté on a du mal
parfois reconnaître un peu les endroits
c'est normal tout est blanc tout à fait
ce sont justement de une façon de
découvrir le territoire autrement et on
retrouve des paysages de 50 ans je
voulais aussi vous avez le temps du
Villa Roy vous avez l'étendue Roussières
différents paysages de 50 ans
effectivement alors autour de
l'exposition il y a également beaucoup
d'animations qu'elles sont elles
puisqu'on accueille beaucoup d'enfants
donc on propose des ateliers pour pour
cette cible là vous avez des ateliers
manuels vous avez la possibilité de
décorer des flocons de neige vous avez
aussi qui permet de découvrir les
animaux de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
vous avez
un atelier où vous pouvez repositionner
justement les photos de l'exposition sur
une carte aérienne du territoire un
espace lecture et également un des
panneaux explicatifs sur la neige et sa
transformation tout à fait au niveau des
animaux c'est quoi les animaux qu'on
peut rencontrer à 50 ans on rencontre
pas de Rennes
vous avez des écureuils des renards des
canards colvert et vous avez également
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié
des lapins oui oui vous avez tout ça sur
il laisse des empreintes dans nos forêts
donc il me reste plus qu'à attendre la
neige alors oui c'est ça merci beaucoup
exposition a lieu jusqu'au 3 janvier
merci alors voilà pour l'exposition
qu'on peut voir à l'Office de Tourisme
jusqu'au début du mois de janvier on va
partir maintenant du côté du château de
Breteuil qui ne prend pas de vacances
pour en parler dans quelques instants
avec nous Irène morphin bonjour vous
êtes guide conférencière et honteuse au
château je voudrais juste vous faire
réagir d'abord parce qu'on a parlé des
animaux qui sont à 50 ans en hiver
est-ce qu'il y a des animaux
particuliers au château de Breteuil je
présume il y a des chevreuils bien sûr
tout ce que les visiteurs peuvent voir
c'est dans les douches qui entourent le
château une famille dedans alors ils
sont blancs parce qu'ils proviennent du
Tibet nous rappelle la neige mais ce
sont très bien acclimatés puisqu'ils ne
sont pas toujours de la neige
en hiver heureusement mais ils se sont
acclimatés ne font des bébés presque
tous les ans donc la famille s'agrandit
donc des dents blancs au château de
Breteuil alors à découvrir on va aussi
parler des visites guidées on va parler
des ateliers compte évidemment et des
ateliers couture il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se passent à Breteuil pendant
ces vacances de Noël et nous avons
d'ailleurs suivi une séance de compte
c'était dimanche dernier il y avait
beaucoup de monde c'est peu de le dire
on regarde
Irène et Natalya ne sont pas simplement
honteux ici au château de Breteuil
certaines redonnent une seconde vie à
ses contes de France et d'ailleurs mais
elle raconte en voix et en musique et
n'hésite pas surtout à faire participer
le public
la visite de Breteuil aussi c'était
sympa chaud un conte vivant très animé
c'était très bien et puis le fait de
participer d'entraîner les enfants donc
ça je trouve très très bien c'était
assez original et puis c'est bien
d'avoir de vrais comteuses et de faire
participer les enfants et le public à
Breteuil pendant toutes les vacances de
Noël le château est ouvert les journées
à la visite et des ateliers couture et
de contes se déroulent des contes de
Noël ou d'hivers ou plus
traditionnellement autour de Charles
Perrault avec toujours le même objectif
faire voyager l'imaginaire il faut
une bonne dose d'humour de savoir-faire
et puis il faut captiver les enfants
avec des débris des il faut très bien
choisir les histoires les séances de
comptes ont lieu tous les jours 16h30 et
écoutez bien alors c'était il y a très
très longtemps dans les sapins on décora
avec ce que l'on trouvait dans les
jardins des noix des pommes de toutes
les couleurs ce jour-là c'était le soir
de Noël on avait décoré dans la maison
et on avait fait le grand ménage ce qui
fait que toutes les petites araignées et
c'était parti se réfugier dans le
grenier dans les caves dans les recoins
quand tout fut silencieux que tout le
monde fut couché les petites araignées
avaient envie de voir ce magnifique
sapin décoré elles sont descendues et
ont sauté de branches en branche depuis
que pique partout partout et elles ont
laissé toute leur toiles d'araignées
partout sur le sapin
partout sur le sapin pour connaître la
suite il faut aller évidemment au
château de de Breteuil il y aura une
marphin en gros bonsoir on l'a vu vous
êtes honteuse avec Natalia exactement et
vous aimez beaucoup faire participer le
public on a vu la jeune enfant qui
devait mimer le regard dans la jungle
c'est important ça oui c'est très
important parce que c'est vrai que les
enfants ont avec les nouveaux médias
notamment
savent moins écouter moins prendre du
temps et le fait de les faire participer
c'est une façon de les intégrer leur
permettre d'identifier aux histoires et
puis c'est très vivant quel type de
compte vous comptez vous raconter en
tout cas pendant cette période de Noël
alors au château de Breteuil on garde
toujours Charles Perrault
puisqu'effectivement lui rend hommage et
c'est une des bases de tous les contes
aujourd'hui mais tous les jours on
ajoute une histoire de Noël un conte
traditionnel et il y a deux séances les
deux dimanches de Noël qui sont
particulières vous avez vu la séance de
dimanche dernier dimanche prochain ça
sera justement sur l'hiver on y revient
on attend tous la neige donc des contes
d'hiver on a fait qu'il y avait beaucoup
de monde beaucoup d'enfants et les
parents étaient aussi extrêmement
captifs comment on arrive justement à
accrocher le public on a vu qu'il y
avait pas simplement je sais pas
simplement de raconter il s'agissait
aussi de faire de la musique de faire
participer
une autre clé c'est l'humour
effectivement on peut dans un compte
trouver plusieurs niveaux de lecture on
ne dit jamais rien qui puisse choquer un
enfant mais on essaye toujours de
glisser des petites choses c'est aussi
une des grandes forces de Charles
Perrault de glisser des petites choses
des commentaires la conteuse et
narratrice elle peut elle-même faire des
commentaires sur sa propre histoire et
faire sourire rire les parents et ça
c'est très important dans notre époque
actuelle et puis vous avez vu la boîte à
Tonnerre on a des instruments de musique
qui permettent de d'apporter une
musicalité au compte alors justement
vous êtes venus avec des instruments de
musique alors présentez-nous certains de
ces instruments alors à Noël forcément
les grelots incontournables vous avez
les chips shimm de table et puis la
kalimba alors la kalimba c'est un
instrument extraordinaire il permet de
faire rêver
de faire revenir au calme de pouvoir
donner des moments de magie au compte on
dirait des petites gouttes d'eau des
petites gouttes d'eau qui tombent
j'aurais revenir sur les comptes de
Charles Perrault effectivement il y a un
lien entre Breteuil et Charles Perrault
quel est ce lien alors Charles Perrault
on le connaît surtout pour ses comptes
mais quand il les écrits il a déjà 69
ans il a eu de grandes fonctions à la
cour du roi Louis XIV à l'époque où
Louis de Breteuil était on va dire
ministre des Finances et lui travaillait
pour lui il a travaillé 10 ans au
finance j'aime à dire qu'il comptait les
pièces d'or avant de compter les
histoires voilà donc c'est en hommage à
cette collaboration que le château de
Breteuil aménage des scènes de combes et
permet d'écouter ces magnifiques contes
de Perrault alors ce qui est
impressionnant aussi chez Charles
Perrault vous l'avez dit les a écrit il
était déjà assez âgé et en plus il en a
écrit j'ai envie de dire que 11 donc il
y a pas beaucoup de cons qui ont été
écrits pourtant il est extrêmement
populaire parce que sur ces 11 comptes
tout sont jusqu'à nous on peut collecter
239 comptes comme on fait les frères
Grimm mais le tout c'est qu'ils arrivent
qu'ils voyagent jusqu'à nous et les
contes de Perrault quand vous faites un
sondage vous demandez aux gens de citer
un compte 9 fois sur 10 il vous cite un
compte de Perrot et puis c'est une manne
aussi pour Walt Disney pour les auteurs
plus contemporains qui reprennent ces
comptes et qui les adaptent au goût du
jour je reviens sur le choix des
décomptes donc dimanche prochain il y
aura vous avez dire des comptes divers
comment vous faites le choix de ces
comptes c'est des contes du monde entier
ah oui bien sûr et puis surtout pour
nous avec ma partenaire Natalia on
choisit des histoires non pas des
histoires de Père Noël qu'on trouve
beaucoup déjà dans les albums d'enfants
mais on s'appuie sur des traditions des
valeurs de Noël et on fait voyager les
gens et donc on s'appuie sur des
traditions dimanche dernier on est parti
en pays celte on est parti en Afrique ça
peut surprendre 30 degrés à Noël
ici voilà et donc du coup on s'appuie
sur les traditions des valeurs et ça
permet de voyager de voir que même si en
fait partout Noël dans le monde c'est
pas toujours de la même façon et vous
travaillez toutes les deux avec Natalia
vous êtes au sein de la compagnie les
tirs chevillettes comment on travaille
ensemble pour raconter des comptes
comment vous vous partagez à la fois la
parole est-ce que chacune a un rôle par
rapport à l'autre je crois qu'on est
très complémentaire donc on a pas mal de
caractère donc on échange Nathalie écrit
un écrivain aussi par ailleurs donc ça
aide et puis ça permet d'avoir un regard
extérieur voilà et du coup on s'écoute
beaucoup il faut beaucoup de complicité
dans un duo et maintenant un trio parce
qu'on nous on a même une musicienne qui
peut faire de l'accordéon du djembé qui
nous accompagne alors là par contre ça
demande beaucoup plus de répétitions
alors pendant ces vacances de Noël donc
il y a les comptes il y a pas que les
comptes aussi à Breteuil il y a
également des ateliers couture il y a
des visites guidées exactement visite
guidée du château qui permet de
découvrir dans chaque pièce des
décorations de Noël vous avez un immense
sapin dans la grande galerie les tables
que ce soit dans la salle à manger ou
aux cuisines ont été décorées par
l'équipe du château toujours des tables
merveilleuses des idées de décoration et
puis les ateliers de Sophie tous les
après-midi
permettent c'est plus large que la
couture ça permet de fabriquer des
masques de fabriquer des éléments de
costume et chaque enfant repart avec sa
petite création il y a aussi le salon de
thé ou les parents peuvent patienter ou
on peut se réchauffer si le froid arrive
il est important de rappeler que
Breteuil est toujours propriété de la
famille de Breteuil et habiter également
par par le compte de Breteuil le marquis
c'est toujours le marquis de Breteuil le
10e marquis le descendant de cette
illustre famille qui gère le domaine qui
dès qu'il le peut accueille les
visiteurs est présent et très investi
dans son château alors avant de nous
quitteren est-ce que vous pourriez nous
raconter enfin nous raconter pardon une
petite histoire encore une
alors faut faire court donc Natalia vous
a raconté le début de l'histoire des
boules de Noël si on se base sur les
traditions une des traditions
à Noël aussi c'est le chocolat forcément
on va tous
se régaler à Noël au réveillon alors ces
petites crottes au chocolat ont un
historique le pays du chocolat c'est la
Suisse alors si on part en Suisse je
vais vous présenter le plus grand
chocolatier du monde Léon mettre Léon
fabrique chaque année des friandises en
chocolat alors une année il avait
fabriqué des guirlandes une autre un
traîneau de Père Noël et puis une année
il fabrique un sapin de Noël en chocolat
il est tellement grand il a été très
inspiré que il tient pas dans sa
boutique alors ils le mettent dehors
dans son jardin comme ça tout le monde
peut venir l'admirer il met une pancarte
interdiction de manger le sapin au
chocolat
tout le monde vient le sapin est là et
le soir de Noël enfin la nuit lorsque le
père Noël fait sa tournée il laisse son
règne le temps de déposer les cadeaux on
obtient sans la bonne odeur des
chocolats il s'approche du sapin ne peut
pas résister et hop un petit coup de
langue
Cric-Crac croc une branche Cric-Crac
croc une boule cricrac croc l'étoile il
est tellement gourmand qui mange tout le
sapin
il a un gros ventre et ça m'a fait des
petits prouts et puis à la place du
Chapin il laisse un petit cadeau tout
chaud des petites crottes de reine
imaginez la surprise de mettre Léon le
lendemain matin plus de sapin
il est vers de rage rouge de colère mais
quand il voit les petites crottes ça lui
donne une idée et ce serait comme ça
qu'il aurait fabriqué les fameuses
crottes en chocolat on mange à Noël pour
la belle histoire merci beaucoup Irène
d'être venu sur le plateau de kiosque
avec grand plaisir
il y a pas de patinoire à Breteuil non
il y a pas de patinoire on attend
peut-être la neige on a tous on annonce
un peu plus de froid donc très joli sous
la neige aussi tout à fait en tout cas
on va maintenant parler de patinoire
puisque deux sont installés sur notre
secteur pendant ses vacances direction
d'abord Versailles pour découvrir une
patinoire écologique de 300 mètres
carrés Florane parfait et le dis-moi
pour le premier week-end des vacances de
Noël ils sont nombreux patineurs
expérimentés ou débutants assez lancé
sur les 300 m² de la patinoire de
Versailles parfois annonçant mal mais
c'est pour leur plus grand bonheur qu'il
teste cette patinoire sans glace ce sont
des plaques en polyènes donc on n'a pas
besoin d'utiliser ni d'eau ni
d'électricité ni de l'école donc on a
une grosse économie d'énergie et les
plaques sont utilisables à nombre de
fois très importantes ce qui fait que
sur le plan écologique par rapport à une
patinoire classique on a beaucoup moins
d'énergie de CO2 utilisés les patins
sont les mêmes que ceux utilisés pour le
hoquet mais à part ça rien ne change les
rires les fleurs les petites ou grosses
frayeurs les parents aux aguets même les
crêpes après les forces sont là verdict
au bout d'une heure de glissade
parce que fonction n'est pas des
professionnels pas besoin d'avoir une
vraie patinoire mais c'est sympa quand
même de pouvoir patiner un peu on débute
avec les enfants alors pour nous ça
change pas grand chose donc mais si on
nous dit que c'est logique on est pour
on vient ça fait pas tout à fait la même
sensation que je ne patie noire normale
ceci étant ça permet de rentrer en
contact avec ce qu'on appelle
communément la glisse je garde mon
petit-fils Thomas et ben c'est
l'occasion de lui faire faire un peu de
sport et de commencer à se dire à
l'initier un petit peu au sport de 10
parce qu'on a l'intention de lampe de
sport d'hiver dans pas longtemps les
températures 12 pour la saison hivernale
ne feront pas fondre cette patinoire
synthétique ouverte jusqu'au 4 janvier
et en cas de chute pas de risque de se
mouiller
voilà et puis une patinoire également
installée devant la mairie de trappes et
ce jusqu'au 4 janvier la patinoire est
ouverte de 14h à 18h la séance d'une
heure revient 1 euro alors patin
chaussée Gand enfilé c'est parti pour la
glisse pour ce bien sûr qui parviennent
à rester debout mais pas de quoi
refroidir les envies
j'ai bien patiné je me suis bien amusé
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont tombés
mais c'est trop bien
pas mal de temps en arrière 2 ans je
crois quelque chose comme ça et c'est
vrai que en plus pour le coup et pour le
temps et ben franchement c'est très
appréciable
Carole Carpier aiguille en courtoises
expose pour la première fois la
médiathèque Saint-Exupéry de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et ce jusqu'au 3
janvier rencontre
ça a démarré depuis mon plus jeune âge
tout simplement où j'avais déjà une
attirance pour l'art mais la révélation
s'est faite on va dire il y a quelques
années où là j'ai décidé presque un 1er
janvier comme une nouvelle résolution
j'ai décidé d'acheter des peintures
enfin de la peinture des pinceaux et des
toiles Carole Carpier débuté par le
dessin mais c'est vers l'art abstrait
que l'artiste s'est orienté il y a 8 ans
beaucoup de choses ont été faites
en figuratif alors que je trouve que
l'abstrait permet d'avoir je dirais un
spectre beaucoup plus large à la
médiathèque Saint-Exupéry de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux Carole Carpier
expose 18 toiles pour définir son style
elle a choisi un adjectif épuré je
dirais des traits
des lignes de repos des aplats mais
aussi parfois un enchevêtrement de
couleur des reliefs la perspective aussi
un mouvement
ces influences elle les a notamment
puisées auprès du peintre français
Georges Mathieu décédé en 2012 le
message qu'elle souhaite faire passer
celui de la sérénité et de l'équilibre
c'est un univers zen
en plus nous sommes à la médiathèque
donc c'est un lieu de lecture de calme
donc je pense que j'ai fait en sorte
d'exposer des oeuvres qui inspiraient
effectivement la à la fois la
contemplation le repos mais
effectivement peut-être une façon aussi
de voyager Carole Carpier continue ses
expositions mais là beaucoup plus loin
que 50 ans en Yvelines elle sera au
Japon au mois de mars prochain
et on poursuit avec la chronique
cinéphile et comme tous les mercredis
les avis de spectateurs éclairés au
micro dès le début one
du père j'adore les animaux et puis les
vues c'est magnifique c'était très bien
très rigolo
on s'est régalé mon avis personnel je va
trouver ça vraiment excellent comme film
il y a des moments sympas donc ils sont
vraiment lassant c'est long et
l'histoire est très on va dire très
compliqué à comprendre moi j'avais vu le
premier donc j'ai trouvé beaucoup mieux
enfin parce que l'histoire elle est
complètement différente et on retrouve
aussi des passages dans du premier qui
sont assez drôles excellent très
émouvant très très fort des acteurs
incroyables c'était intense c'était
c'était passionnel parce que c'était
l'histoire d'un musicien et de jazz et
voilà j'ai pas l'occasion d'écouter
souvent du jazz c'était l'occasion j'ai
bien aimé c'était pas mal j'ai été un
peu déçue
oui je serais pas l'expliquer mais je
m'attendais à mieux en fait il y a tout
on s'attend à des choses on les voit
toutes donc c'est bien il y a pas de
manquement et de mauvaises surprises
j'ai bien aimé que Dieu soit représenté
par un enfant en fait Dieu n'était pas
caricatural donc j'ai bien aimé pour ça
c'est un très bon film c'est un bon
péplum quoi c'est une belle histoire
et pour finir cette émission je vous
propose maintenant de vous projeter sur
l'année prochaine avec une sélection de
spectacles à voir en famille tout
d'abord direction l'espace Philippe
Noiret au Clayes-sous-Bois pour un
spectacle jeune public de théâtre
d'ombres trompette le petit téléphone
sera donné le samedi 10 janvier à 11h
trompette décide de partir à la
découverte du monde pour se faire des
amis en chemin il rencontre Victorine la
tortue Léna l'hirondelle on regarde un
extrait
sur une petite pierre je me suis
retrouvé les quatre fers en l'air je
suis pas bien maligne je m'appelle
Victorine même nation derrière au fond
tirer d'affaires
oh oui soyons amis tu m'as sauvé la vie
et en gage d'amitié
je vais te présenter tous mes amis
ça c'est absolument adorable un
spectacle maintenant mise en scène par
Béranger bon voisin sur des textes du
premier roman de Romain Gary un
spectacle tout en tendresse gros câlin
interprété par Jean Quentin Chatelain ce
spectacle sera joué deux fois les 6 et 7
janvier à 20h30 au Théâtre de 50 ans en
Yvelines tarif à partir de 6 euros 50
lorsqu'un python s'enroule autour de
vous et vous serre bien fort la taille
les épaules et à plus ça peut être
contre votre coup vous n'avez qu'à
fermer les yeux pour vous sentir
tendrement
de tirer votre épingle du jeu
mais de bouleverser tous les rapports du
jeu avec deux je n'ai rien compris et
pour finir cette agenda de l'année 2015
Michel Fugain et pluribus seront sur les
planches du Théâtre espace Coluche de
plaisir vendredi 9 janvier à 21h pour un
spectacle à 12 musiciens où il y a la
seule règle est qu'il n'y en a pas
justement de règles tarif entre 34 et 38
euros on regarde un
extraits
sont dans la tête
dans
la joie de Michel Fugain ce sera le 9
janvier au Théâtre parce qu'au luge de
plaisir kiosque c'est terminé pour cette
année rendez-vous en direct mercredi à 7
janvier je recevrai Jacques dors
pianiste pour la présentation d'une
intégrale des pièces de Chopin je vous
souhaite évidemment d'excellentes fêtes
de fin d'année qu'elle soit animée
joyeuse et bien sûr culturelle à très
vite